let me break it down very simple for you
the world plays in the middle and all
the action is in the edges you got your
perspective don't you want to be happy
[Music]
number what is up what is up [ __ ] I've
been flying for two days but I'm here
and I'm excited to be here thank you for
having me thanks for the warm welcome
there's a lot of places I want to go
with today's talk and so let's just get
right into it I think for me what I
really want to accomplish in this talk
today is set up a framework of strategy
of how much abundance and opportunity
there is right now and why and then
number to really get into the tactics
that I think a lot of people here can
take and take whatever they're trying to
achieve to the next place I think the
thing that as I you know I was getting
ready for this trip and I was really
looking at a lot of the things on
Facebook and Instagram and Twitter and
other things that nature that have
become such an important part of the way
I think about the world but more
importantly before we go into that what
I was doing over the last month as this
kind of conference was coming together
was I'm are you really wearing a
Patriots [ __ ] shirt Jesus just
completely took my energy to a different
place punch that dude in the face
as I was getting ready for this talk it
what I was really looking at were people
that were making references to it and
then kind of going down the rabbit hole
especially on the flight out here after
I caught up with all my work and still
had 20 hours of flying as people were
referencing this conference I was able
to kind of go into their accounts and
take a look at what they were doing how
they were doing it and what's become
really remarkably interesting to me over
the last you know half decade and
especially over the last couple years is
how many people hear me understand or
consume a lot of the content but are
unable because of patience I guess or
many other reasons how many people's
actions don't map I mean literally the
amount of people that I'll post
something about something they'll jump
in and be like yeah guarantee you're
right and then I click their calendar
literally doing the complete opposite in
that hypocrisy in that misunderstanding
in that white space is really the thing
that matters to me I think the first
thing that everybody needs to really
wrap their head around and understand
about this era is how much attention is
really being put here and how much if
you're not winning on this device how
much vulnerability you have number two
really understanding that we talked a
lot about content but nobody here
including me with a humongous team and
this is super important this is really
what I wanted to start this talk with
because I think it will help people me
with a team of 20 putting out between 80
and a hundred pieces of original content
a day and grossly under performing in
the amount of content I put out every
day like to really set the tone for
everybody the volume the sheer volume of
content needed for every individual or
business in this room to be successful
in a 20-19 environment is staggering and
nobody's really making the financial or
mental or emotional investment into that
level of content the amount of people
that are super fine with putting out 1
or 2 piece
or three pieces a day on one platform
are just leaving an enormous amount of
opportunity on the table and so for me
if there's anything that I can get
through today and there'll be plenty of
things I'll try to get through but the
sheer amount of content needed to take
full advantage of this land grab is
staggering and so that comes in a lot of
forms for me the reason I'm so obsessed
with people focusing on video is because
the reality is is that video creates a
scenario that allows you to do images
and written word and audio on the back
of filming for me the reason I do a vlog
daily is because we're able to use that
as a top of the funnel piece of content
and then I'm able to produce a podcast
I'm able to produce the quote pictures
you see on Instagram the written
articles on my dot-com and LinkedIn it
is the top of the funnel that creates
everything else instead of bottom up
it's unbelievably important if you're
fortunate enough to be here and you feel
okay to be in front of the camera you
need to lean in you need to absolutely
and then I think there's a lot of people
and by the way I'm a big believer that
you have to bet on your strengths and be
self-aware I think there's a lot of
people here who wish they were something
and the reality is forcing that is their
vulnerability if you're not comfortable
being in front of the camera for
whatever millions of reasons or whatever
insecurity that's super fine and you
should lean into audio on your phone or
if you're a great writer you need to
figure out how you communicate but let
let there be no confusion here today if
you are not producing content for the
Internet
you are basically non-existent in our
society if you have you know regardless
of how good your b2b business is doing
or how great your real-estate firm is or
financial service like Sears was winning
- at one point like regardless of how
well you're doing you were vulnerable
right this minute because all of the
attention on a daily basis continues to
funnel here and whatever excuse you come
up with which is my audience is not on
there or my industry isn't affected
all those things become your great
vulnerability I recently just a couple
weeks ago completely changed the
strategic and create a foundation of
where vaynermedia my company's going and
a lot of people in my inner circle
pushed against it because they're like
we're doing well and I reminded them I
like look I'm desperate to put us out of
business before somebody else does it
for us how many people here are having
their best financial year personally or
in their business raise your hands let's
clap it up for them one more time raise
them high no reason to be embarrassed
about that keep it up to me the people
with their hands up in that scenario are
the ones that I'm most worried about
because when it's going well is often
times when people become complacent or
they don't think the thing matters for
them and so for me those are the things
that really really stand out I think the
other thing to really pay attention to
is attention itself for me attention has
been the thing I've bless you that I've
chased my whole career you know when I
was selling lemonade I would look at
polls and did you just get naked bro
shit's getting crazy here in Melbourne
this rose [ __ ] up the Patriot fandom
naked dude I hope they paid extra just
like over dudes like [ __ ] naked
attention has been something that I've
been chasing my whole career selling
lemonade against you know really was
interesting to me it took me about four
or five years ago when I finally
realized that it wasn't I wasn't setting
up the tables or making the lemonade
I was really spending all my time
looking at the cars and trying to figure
out where to put the posters and the
signs to get people's attention I did
that in baseball cards and I did it in
wine and I've done it pretty much my
entire career and I think the thing that
a lot of people need to focus on is
where is the attention so for example 24
months ago I would not stand up here and
push LinkedIn very heavily you know the
platform was pretty much for anybody
that understands LinkedIn has been
around it it was really something where
people put up their you know resumes it
was something that people really spammed
each other on right LinkedIn became a
shitty place for all of us because all
it was was people emailing in bulk with
no context and then about three years
ago four years ago they made it more of
a Content play and you started seeing a
little bit more and they had some
influence on it and I was on and it was
fine but over the last 18 to 24 months
it's been remarkable how much
opportunity there is on LinkedIn and if
you're in this audience and you're doing
b2b marketing and you do not have a
LinkedIn content strategy
you're making a humungous mistake
because when you layer on top of it ads
that allow you to target the titles of
the occupations that you're trying to
reach how many people here are in b2b
raise your hands I mean to the enormous
percentage of this audience and I
continue to watch b2b companies not
create original content for LinkedIn and
when they do they're much more in a
commercial or you know sales oriented
way not in a branding and create content
way I always tell people if you make
content on the Internet as if you're the
TV show not the commercials in between
the TV show you will get
disproportionate return on your
investment the problem is is most people
are looking for instant gratification
and return on their investment the
amount of people here who've run a
thousand dollars in
adds on something it didn't work and
they deemed it as it doesn't work is
staggering to me
I have spent millions of dollars on
Facebook and Twitter and Instagram and
Google that haven't worked I've also
spent millions of dollars on those
platforms that have worked the execution
of the creative is the variable in that
environment just because you ran a
thousand dollars or ten thousand dollars
in facebook ads and it didn't work it
might be the picture or video that you
put in front of people
sucked and didn't compel them to buy
anything the attentions under price
there is no doubt the attentions
massively underpriced I built my
family's wine business on underpriced
attention on email and Google AdWords
those were the early 2000s I know what
it looks like it's exactly what's
happening right now with Facebook and
Instagram and influencers they're just
under priced pre-roll podcast under
priced there is no debate that the
attention is underpriced there's a
reason that wish the shopping app does
six billion dollars in revenue on the
back of 98% Facebook ads it's under
priced but are you capable to create
contextual creative at scale that's the
question
can you produce ninety seven pieces of
content for ninety seven different
demographics and psychographics and then
run ads against them to compel them to
buy your things if I'm selling sneakers
which I do there's gonna be a
fundamental difference of the video or
picture I'm gonna put it in front of
somebody who's eighteen white male in
New York City versus a forty
seven-year-old Latino woman with two
kids in Texas
the problem is when auditing the 30
accounts that I looked at here and the
hundreds of thousands I do a year 99% of
people make 1 to 5 pieces of content and
run their ads and expect something to
happen it is fundamentally not
contextual to the audience that they're
trying to reach very simply put
everybody everybody's running creative
ads media marketing right now as if it
was 1997 and the only
options you had was the newspaper the
billboard the radio and the television
meanwhile we have Facebook and Instagram
and influencers that allow us to go way
more longtail the problem is people have
been put in the time and effort to
create the content that's contextual to
the psychographics and demographics so
and I'm going very [ __ ] nerdy because
I'm [ __ ] fired up right now on this I
think that every person in here
regardless of what they're trying to do
whether they're trying to run for mayor
raise money for a charity or sell their
services needs to have at least 13 to 30
core audiences that they produce content
for every time so literally every time
you have something new going on you have
to create 30 variations where the copy I
mean you could target people who are
divorced you can target people have two
to two kids you can target [ __ ] who
like the Patriots you can do so much you
can do so much with this medium yet
people are mailing it in meanwhile
they're also having ludicrous there are
ludicrous conversations going on like
people having ego around how well they
do organically on these platforms when
the ads are massively underpriced do you
know how many people email me crying
that Facebook's
organic reach declined three years ago
as if Facebook screwed them while
Facebook is literally free to use do you
know many people here are starting to
get concerned that they're not getting
as many likes and views on their
Instagram account because they can feel
something's happening yet it's free
I really need to like drill this home
people are mad at the algorithm on
Instagram they run ads everywhere else
they buy a booth at a conference
they run print Direct Mail costs money
you start an Instagram account if you
don't run ads you can organically build
an audience and you post now you're mad
that you're not reaching as many people
and you've got this big conspiracy anger
at the algorithm yet you haven't paid a
[ __ ] dime for the platform like I
drank that beer quick it's a very
intriguing thing for me that people have
emotional opinions about something they
haven't paid for and so here's the game
and it will always be the game things
come along there underpriced real estate
stocks attention when they're under
priced you need to strike and squeeze as
much as you can out of them I will come
back to Melbourne in six years and spend
my entire talk trying to get people to
stop running ads on Facebook and
Instagram that will happen it's always
happened to me it's the same old game
you take advantage when it's under
priced and you squeeze it as long as you
can you ride it all the way through and
eventually the long tail catches up and
it becomes overpriced because big
companies come in and it becomes
overpriced because of the bidding and
normal people stop paying attention as
much everybody here who's been on
Facebook for five plus years
pays attention to every piece of content
on Facebook a little less than they did
five years ago or maybe a lot less that
is just the natural cadence of what we
do how many people here had email in the
late 90s
raise your hands old [ __ ] so all the
people that just raised their hands what
they can tell everybody here under 30 is
what we used to do with email in the 90s
which was we read every single email
wine library's email service in nine
99 was almost 90 percent open rates how
many people here have done email
marketing in their career raise your
hands 90 percent open rates it's
ridiculous it's like 32 now and I think
we feel like we're heroes so that will
happen with these platforms so look
before I get into the mindset and the
strategy and some of the social things
I'm seeing going on I'll go back into
the details but the details are very
simple and I said it when I was here
last year and I'm gonna say it again if
you are not a practitioner yet of making
content and running ads on Facebook and
Instagram you will massively regret it
and the reason that you've seen me
saying in every video I am putting it
down on film to recall it in a decade I
will never stop saying it I don't care
how much you're tired of hearing it and
hoping for something new I'm not gonna
make up something that isn't true
they are grossly underpriced the one
little add-on that I've been saying a
lot more over the last month or so than
in the past is how much content you need
to produce and the reason one of the
breakthrough videos I've ever made
called
document don't create worked is it's
hard to create a new video that's
creative that's hard but if you actually
film your day to day your meetings your
mundane there's absolute action in that
and so I'd highly recommend really
understanding what that means let's take
a step back and let's talk about
something I've been spending a lot of
time on which is in a world where I'm
asking you to create so much content the
fact that so many of you do not create
content because you're so bent out of
shape by the feedback in the comments
section this has become a remarkable
fascination of mine that people
literally aren't living their lives to
their happiness or fullest because Sally
Pants 36 said that you're ugly or fat
people absolutely crippled by the
judgment of others without really
understanding what it is let me say it
here right now so there's no confusion
if a human being
takes the time out of their day to
consume your piece of content consume it
and then spend time to leave a negative
comment to you after consuming your
content think about how shitty that
person's life is somebody literally has
the time to consume your content and try
to drag you down my friends misery loves
company is one of the most interesting
sayings that has been in culture for a
long time it most manifests in a very
poor way when I watch parents drag their
kids into [ __ ] cuz they're upset but
it's one thing and I have empathy a lot
of it when it's your mom and dad
dragging you through [ __ ] cuz that's
deep but when an anonymous person with a
[ __ ] icon of a rugby player is
dragging you through [ __ ] you have to
get into a place where that does not
bother you it makes zero sense I mean
literally and I get [ __ ] on all the time
you get that many comments you get [ __ ]
on when I see it it's the only I mean I
don't feel bad for me I genuinely feel
bad for them I'm fascinated I've never
in my life taking the time consume
somebody's content and then [ __ ] on them
it makes absolutely no sense so please
if you're one of these individuals and
there are a lot of you in this audience
that are not producing content because
you're worried about the judge you know
many people email me Gary but I have to
put on makeup why because your grandma
told you when you were seven
but Gary the lighting why you don't like
the bags under your eyes good news
everybody has bags under eyes like there
is an enormous amount of insecurity in
the system that is stopping people from
creating the things they want and it
needs to be talked about in a much
bigger way the judgment of others is a
fascinating thing how many people by
show of hands work in a job and are
desperate for their side hustle to
become their career just raise your
hands raise them hi can you stand up
I need to see this cuz I gotta get a
sense stand up if this is your mo your
side hustle you're desperate for that to
become your career good amount okay
thank you for doing that so I'll go into
this so this has become a new thing that
I've been spending a ton of time on
something I've realized that really kind
of caught me off guard is how many
people spend more money on [ __ ] than
they can afford and I know that's like a
funny thing to say but it's actually
very basic I'm actually talking about
the amount of people that have emailed
me in the last six months because I've
been on this rant lately of trying to
get people to move back in with their
parents at 30 and 40 yeah I'm hot on
this it's because there's this
incredible thing how many people here
own their home raise your hands
the people that just raised their hands
90% of people that own their homes don't
use more than 50% of their home they
have three extra bedrooms that they
don't need they have a living and dining
room and a [ __ ] den and all sorts of
[ __ ] the amount of people who live in
homes that they've extended themselves
financially to afford that don't use
half of that home is fascinating the
amount of people who are in debt so they
can drive a car that has a logo on it
that makes them feel better because
that's keeping up with the Joneses or
other people's judgment is fascinating
to me what I didn't realize was the fact
that thirty [ __ ] five percent of this
audience wants their side hustle to be
their careers but the reason they can't
is because they can't quit their job
because they need their job to pay for
dumb [ __ ] to impress people they [ __ ]
hate
and so especially while the economy
globally is frothy I am aggressively
throwing up for debate to the third of
this audience that is trying to get
their side hustle to be their job for
them to give a real thought to what it
would look like if they were to downsize
their home and their car and their
vacations and their watch to put
themselves in a position to be happy I
think over the next decade as we
continue to start really discovering as
a human race mental health and happiness
that we are on the pre Dawn's of people
changing what success looks like when I
really look at the world and I've I grew
up super humbly I've spent my ten years
ago career in the in the explosion of
Silicon Valley I've really been lucky to
see all sorts of different things going
on
it is super cliche but absolutely true
that the money Happiness thing is just a
funny thing people that don't have it
think it does bring happiness people
that have it no it's not true and when
you really look at suicide data and
things depression data it's fascinating
who struggles with it I really do
believe as we become dramatically more
thoughtful about happiness versus money
that a lot of people are gonna start
really looking at the things they amass
and how much that is a choker to their
happiness and so what really excites me
right now is how frothy the economy is
globally and I know so many of you can
take advantage of selling high
positioning yourself to be happy I think
it's a very rogue point of view it's
completely against the propaganda that
you see in your Instagram and Facebook
feed 24/7 everybody's pushing all sorts
of fancy stuff and fancy trips and fancy
things I genuinely believe that the
majority of people here can dramatically
matically put themselves in a happier
place if they honestly consider
downsizing things that they don't use so
just a random thought that I'm super
passionate about let me talk to you guys
about influencer marketing for me I
talked to earlier about underpriced
attention and overpriced attention the
way you get those things is when the
market doesn't understand itself when
people don't understand how underpriced
Facebook is they don't put money into it
thus the prices stay down the most
inefficient and misunderstood market
place in my opinion is influencer
marketing humans don't know how to price
themselves there are pretty people that
have 400,000 followers on Instagram that
won $30,000 a post and there are other
people with 5,000 followers who want 40
bucks there are 400,000 person follower
people that want a hundred bucks there
are people with 500 followers that want
$5,000 the inefficiency in influencer
marketing is staggering how many people
here by show of hands and you guys have
been pretty bullshitty with your hands I
don't know what's scaring you but go
high how many people here sell an actual
product physical raise your hands a lot
every single person one more time hands
in the air all of you all of you that
have your hands in the air should have a
significant influence err thank you
influencer marketing strategy literally
DMing people on Instagram and asking
them how much they would charge you to
take a picture holding your physical
product and tagging your page it is
massively inefficient which is I love
when people like Gary how do you scale
it by DMing more people [ __ ]
the it's just there's no machine or
algorithm just get nice and cozy and DM
people and ask them one by one if they
are willing to do it I often find that
the biggest upsides often is scaling
things that are not scalable scaling
things that are not scalable comes from
sheer effort and time and so if one more
time I just want to get the physical
selling a product physically if if I was
your partner buddy with the hat selling
physical I would spend thirty to fifty
percent of my overall marketing budget
on influencer marketing it's so
inefficient and if you're lucky enough
that your product you sell directly on
your Shopify or Amazon like you can see
it you don't even have to guess you
literally run either codes or just
isolated time slots for certain
influencers and you can see what the
return on the investment is there's been
many influencers that we bought that we
weren't sure and then we bought 50 times
over because their audience was
converting because they had an authentic
audience I couldn't be more passionate
about it and it is wildly under priced
in this market down here it's under
priced everywhere but we've even debated
opening of vaynermedia office in
Australia just on the back just on the
back of really influencer marketing
because it's so underserved in the
marketplace and I highly recommend you
take a deep look at it another thing
that is unbelievably under priced in
this market and globally is keyword and
AD word Google searches and then
retargeted on YouTube pre-roll video so
imagine a scenario where people search
on Google for curtains were a financial
advisor and how many people here have
done Google advertising further in their
careers raise your hands
perfect so a lot of you know it was an
incredibly powerful platform because it
was intent-based
if they were searching for it that means
they were interested in it and it would
convert and a lot of you did extremely
well with it
because it converted highly much easier
to be good at Google at first than
Facebook at first Facebook is branding
Google is selling very different game
selling is a hell of a lot easier in the
short term which is why people like it
branding and marketing takes time which
is why people bail on it the problem is
Nike and Adidas and coca-cola that's
branding our [ __ ] businesses is
selling you understand but there is a
combination of selling and branding that
is super powerful and it plays out on
Facebook but it also plays out on
YouTube YouTube for everybody that
doesn't know is the second biggest
search engine in the world for people
like me that can't read for [ __ ] when
you want to go on YouTube and hear it or
watch it visually you understand it it's
incredibly powerful but besides that
what's unbelievable is there is a way
for you to actually target people that
search on Google for something they so
let's use my old world they search for
Margaret River Cabernet on Google to buy
3 days later they go on YouTube to watch
a video of how to hang a picture on
their wall and the pre-roll YouTube
video goes hey are you in the market for
Margaret River Cabernet and then you're
like holy [ __ ] they're spying on me cuz
you [ __ ] forget that you searched for
it three days ago on google for me when
I thought about this talk and coming
here today I said to myself look there's
three or four things that are just
black-and-white tactics that if I get
people to actually do they will feel
benefits it's funny how I think about
marketing no different than Fitness
people are always always far more
interested in finding some rare [ __ ]
fruit deep in the Amazon that they can
eat that makes them lose fat then
actually [ __ ] working out an eating
healthy dick like you're far more
excited to buy some [ __ ] pill that
was found in Saturn
brought back then you are to do the very
basics it's super stunning eat healthy
and workout every day it's super basic
but nobody wants to actually put in the
work I've literally spent the last 30
minutes giving you 3 to 4 basic things
that are real as [ __ ]
99% of you even though all of you wrote
little notes are not gonna do [ __ ] about
it
you're gonna write it down you say yeah
this is you know what I've heard him say
to bunch this is the time I'm definitely
gonna go back and do that and the next
Thursday happens and something good or
bad happens in your business and you
completely put this talk on the shelf
let me be very clear with you in October
of 2018 in Australia if you run Facebook
and Instagram ads against 30 to 50
different pictures and videos against
whatever you're trying to accomplish in
your business it will work let me make
it perfectly clear for you in October
2018 if you spend five hours a day going
to direct messaging influencers that
could possibly sell your product and
getting a third of them 8% of them to
agree to post a picture holding up your
product and tagging your product it will
work let me make it perfectly clear for
you in October of 2018
if you run pre-roll YouTube video
against search query on Google of
whatever you're trying to do in this
room it will work now I just need to ask
you why you're not doing it because if
you've come to this conference to see me
speak you've heard this [ __ ] 40 [ __ ]
thousand times I can't wrap my head
around it I can because I watched it
every day it's human behavior I see it
but the reason I get passionate to keep
doing this is I've learned sometimes it
just takes that 19 time and you actually
sitting in the audience to do it bless
you what really really shocks me though
and what really excites me as being in
the like this is my schpeel
in America the most advanced competitive
market for all of my concepts the fact
that everything I just told you is
disproportionately even more exciting
here
the reason we opened up a London office
for Vayner the reason we're opening up
Singapore next February the reason I
keep going global is it's like going
into a [ __ ] time machine like it's
working better here it's cheaper here
because the bigger companies here are
even slower than the big companies in
America so the big money's not in you
need to take advantage of this you are
going to regret it
you're gonna regret it and let me tell
you this this is a good Segway an
incredible random [ __ ] thing that I
can tell you to do is to go volunteer at
a retirement home one day this year a
very random thing that can fundamentally
change your life business-wise let me
just not even go human in your business
is go and volunteer in a retirement home
once for five hours let me give you the
preview for the 99.9% of you that won't
do that you will see human beings with
regret in their eye and I promise you
for whatever scary [ __ ] you've seen
abuse murder scariest [ __ ] you've ever
seen there's nothing scarier than to
stare a human being in the face who
understands she or he [ __ ] up and
there's no going back
regret there's macro and micro regret
macro regrets of who you married what
you didn't do did it it uh and there's
micro regrets and in the context of this
talk the micro gret in a business world
is you're sitting on a golden goose it
will take you five to seven hours to
Google it to figure out how to run a
Facebook ad and please Melbourne please
do me a huge favor do not hire your 22
year old niece and think she's gonna
know how to do it just because she grew
up with this [ __ ] and you didn't I love
with you Gary but you know I didn't grow
up with this [ __ ]
neither did I dick I'm 42 I didn't grow
up with this now let me tell you
something else
you didn't grow up driving and you
figured that out this is something you
have to learn you want to have a
business you want your side hustle like
I love when people like do people
understand how hard it
is to live your life for yourself on
your terms and make money have we had
the right conversations yet about this
to live as your own boss and make enough
money to have a good life as a that's a
1% thing in our society and everybody
has this level of entitlement and
especially now trust me I'm feeling it
I'm the beneficiary of it but now that
we've made entrepreneurs cool the whole
thing's totally [ __ ] everybody thinks
entrepreneurship so easy this [ __ ] is
super hard it's super hard to be good
enough to make that kind of money
because even though the Internet's here
and everybody in this room has the
chance to do it the problem is the
Internet's here and everybody here has a
chance to do it and supply-and-demand
takes over I love people who are like
Gary but my content it's not doing well
but it's because people don't get it I'm
too ahead of the curve no you're not Ron
you just suck you're not a head of [ __ ]
the market is the market is the market
you have 39 views on your YouTube it
means you suck it means it's not
interesting or it means that you're
early so many people like Gary I'm lost
you're not lost you're 27 you've just
started this is a long game and the
opportunity is substantial but there are
two very important things the world my
friends let me let me break it down very
simple for you the world plays in the
middle and all the action is in the
edges the world plays in the middle it's
what school does to us makes you in the
middle all the opportunities in the
extreme of micro and macro you have to
like I always talk about macro slow
micro fast right micro speed
I work 17 hours a day I'm booked every
minute micro speed yet I'm in year 9 of
building vaynermedia in the prime of my
career not making that much money as
much as I could to build a machine for
for the next 30 years in the macro slow
all of the action is in the edges having
ridiculous blind confidence equally
having the humility to know that you
don't mean [ __ ] going all in and having
the ability to completely pivot if you
know it's wrong there's such a fine line
between perseverance and delusion it's
such a fascinating thing for me to watch
and so my friends I promise you there is
so much abundance I hate watching people
get upset when other people win without
realizing how much abundance in the
system nobody on earth success is coming
at your expense everybody thinks this is
a binary game it's just not there's so
much abundance and so we in general in
the macro have to desperately get our
mindsets right we are collectively
stunningly not patient enough everybody
wants it tomorrow we are unbelievably
lacking perspective the dumb [ __ ] that I
hear people complaining about every day
is stunning you know we every buddy here
needs to start joining more nonprofits
and getting in the field you go join a
nonprofit like charity water and you go
to Africa and you watch people walk
seven and a half miles every day for
fresh water you start struggling to
complain to the barista because he or
she put the wrong milk in your [ __ ]
coffee
we need perspective we need passion we
need patience we need a lot of things
and then you have to let it play out
everything I've ever done two core
things have always been the theme and
for anybody who's dreaming or thinking
differently I really need you to hear
this the everything I've ever done
professionally two things have happened
one it's taken forever for it to
manifest because I was early number two
nobody agreed with me and
people snickered and made fun of me
every time I did them if you're looking
to innovate and do something special you
have to recognize exactly what's going
to happen which is the voices the voices
are going to be the game that you have
to play out the one that's become most
fascinating to me over the last year
because I get so much interaction on
this is the people and I'm just gonna
say so this is completely just random
but I'm hopeful it might help just one
person in this audience if the voice in
your own head says to you that you suck
I desperately need you to know that
somebody put that voice in your head if
the voice in your head tells you to
yourself that you suck somebody put it
in there and you have to understand it
usually you're [ __ ] up mom but you
have to wrap your head around that
because it's really difficult for me to
watch so many people not act based on
that own voice the biggest thing that
people aren't acting on is they're not
taking risk because they're scared to
lose and they're scared to then have
people judge them on that loss it is
remarkable to me how easy it is for me
to see a true bred entrepreneur versus
one that's not a true bred entrepreneur
loves to lose it is scary to me how much
I love losing publicly love my
investment I love talking about passing
on uber twice love it I love when people
literally leave comments like don't
listen to this guy he passed on uber
twice and then I look at their account
they have nine followers and they
[ __ ] suck [ __ ] and I'm like yo bro
but I didn't pass on Facebook and venmo
and Twitter what are you doing you're
[ __ ] playing fortnight and jerking
off 24/7
anyway um I'm obsessed with losing
because something that I really want
people to wrap their head around is when
you lose it's your loss
we have so much judgment out there and
we lack context I laughed when people
tell people how to raise their children
you're not in that person's home I laugh
when people talk about other people's
relationships you're not behind that
closed door I laughed when people give
advice on how to run a business you're
not in it if you notice the read the
biggest reason I stay very macro and
just give details of what you can do is
there's so much judgment being thrown
out there to everybody and nobody knows
[ __ ] everybody's running out with
judgment nobody knows [ __ ] about what's
actually happening judgment is poison my
friends and this world right now because
of social media specifically because you
can see all the judgment I love when
people think social media changed us my
friends so should be they exposed us
nobody's changed you used to be a dick
to you just said it to yourself and to
three other people in your neighborhood
now you can say it to everybody publicly
online it's like money and fame it
doesn't change you it exposes who you
actually are and so we're living in a
very transcendent world and so you're
either gonna look at the negatives or
the shortcomings or you're gonna look at
the positives for me I see all positives
I love that we're going through all this
[ __ ] globally with ourselves because we
needed to be exposed of on weaknesses
one step backwards two steps forward
that same machine do you nobody people
say to me Gary I don't think Facebook
and Instagram that stuff isn't work yet
in the other mouth during that same
dinner all they talk about is how social
media is [ __ ] up the government or
countries or the world literally you're
telling me that Facebook's powerful
enough to change the global world and
governments but it's not powerful enough
to sell some of your t-shirts or your
landscaping business services my friends
take it for what it is we are all
obnoxiously fortunate to be living
through this era right now
what this era is just to quantify it is
we are now at the maturity of the
internet the internet now is that scale
we all live there it is real it's not
what I grew up with which it was coming
it is here it is at scale and the
reality of the situation is how many
people one more time with side hustles
raise your hands
everyone stand up again side hustle to
turn into your business I need this
because this is the point side hustle to
turn into your business
I just need every single person that's
standing to understand one thing your
grandparents couldn't even dream to turn
a side hustle into their business
because the internet didn't [ __ ]
exist they just had to eat [ __ ] and live
their life and put food on the table and
a roof over their head and then [ __ ]
die
I'm being serious we are so outlandish
ly fortunate to have this era and what
everybody's doing is spending all their
time deploying cynicism and looking at
the things that are negative about it
without realizing it is the full
empowerment to whatever you want if
you're willing to be a practitioner and
actually learn this [ __ ] and execute it
this era will go away many of you follow
me no I'm all focused on voice and
Alexan all this it's all gonna happen
[ __ ] changes whether it's blockchain or
AR or VR or voice this internet era this
golden era as we stand here today will
go away and then for the same reason
that I didn't make any [ __ ] videos
for five years cuz I had nothing to say
there won't be a great deal like
influencers and Instagram and Facebook
and you will deploy regret because
you've heard me pound it down your
throat and you did nothing about it
so please Melbourne do me a [ __ ]
favor on my 37 [ __ ] hour flight to
get here please make this event this
talk the time that you actually go home
and start [ __ ] executing because I'll
be very honest with you I'm [ __ ]
tired of the thousand 1000 emails every
week that I get that are the same exact
thing
titled I don't know why it took me four
and a half years of listening to the
same [ __ ] to finally do it but I'm
really glad I did because in the last
seven months I've made $80,000 and
before I used to be $40,000 in debt
please make tonight the beginning of the
next chapter of your life because when
it goes away I'm gonna get quiet and
execute and you're gonna wish you're
gonna wish you did something about it
tonight thank you that's true Q&A not
done yet we're not done yet we had uh
you guys learned something yeah very
good turn the person next to get my
high-fives I'm glad he came stop giving
high-fives and go [ __ ] run some ads
that goes let me tell you something they
didn't learn [ __ ] if they follow me they
know this is not about learning
I've pounded this for [ __ ] two years
this is about doing this is [ __ ]
exercise you know what to do you still
eat cupcakes fat ass got it
that's what's going on here [ __ ]
seriously though like by the way just
give you a preview I'm a nice guy now or
if you think cursings mean but I'm a
nice guy if you look under I'm gonna be
very meaning for years when everyone's
crying about this I'm gonna be jumping
in and be like you [ __ ] ass I told
you I'm gonna be razzing the [ __ ] out of
people sorry question number one this
came from people that are in the
audience here today so these questions
are from you all first question is from
Henry Vila question about gratitude what
do you do when someone gives you an
opportunity and you know you will never
be able to pay it back you know Henry
you got to take that as a gift right and
the reality is you don't know that
you'll never be able to you know give it
back like this is what I always talk
about like how dangerous Envy is and not
having context like I always tell people
like people like the amount of people
that throw lucky or other things at me
they're like I'm like look sure but what
about tomorrow
if my daughter gets hit by a bus and
dies am I then lucky and I know I know
that's but that's not how I think like
for Henry like you don't think you can
give that person anything back today
that's just not how life works like you
might be able to so I accept the gift
and be grateful try to help other people
in ways you can but if you're so fixated
on helping the person that put you on
recognize that life ebbs and flows who's
winning today loses tomorrow and vice
versa
it's a [ __ ] marathon and everybody's
just judging today without understanding
tomorrow I spend all my time
anticipating tomorrow
that's the rant that I just gave for 45
minutes so that's how I think about it
yeah very good next question what is
your number one tip for growing a wealth
and investment advisory firm in the
digital age where access to information
is so easy how do you get to be number
one I mean number one comes in all
shapes and sizes so I mean to me it's
just the process of aspiring to be great
I think it's about for me where the
information is free it becomes
especially in wealth investment
things of that nature it becomes a
personal brand world like people buy
from people like that's just a way it's
always been and so the more and by the
way the biggest reason so many people
lose and legal or wealth or things of
that nature is they front-right they
play a character on social media now who
they actually are right and so like as
you can imagine in 2008-9 I missed out
on ninety percent of my speaking
engagements cuz I cursed it was less
acceptable than it is today I still do
but I didn't know how not to be me and
that was just the way it was gonna be I
think a lot of people try to be the
person in their LinkedIn profile even
though they hate wearing a [ __ ] tie
and I think the more you can be yourself
and just like talk about the things
you're actually into there's more people
that would get business in this country
talking about footy then talking about
the actual skill set they have and
managing someone's money it's a personal
game you say inside of there if I just
say ask you a question you said
something you said the process of
aspiring to be great I think it's so
powerful where does that come from for
you the process of aspire to be great I
just love my game I love my game like I
don't want to win because I want to keep
playing like I never wanted to end right
like once you find what you love to do
like you've won and so for me I'm trying
to get better at it all the time but
it's I'm not fixated on being number one
or having the most money or revenue I'm
just in my own little insular circle
just enjoying it and trying to get
better at it and letting the chips fall
I mean it's incredible how little I know
about anybody else that does anything
that I do I've I've never watched
anybody give a talk in my life I've
never I've never read a business book in
my life I've never listened to a
complete podcast of anybody's podcast
I'm sure they're great I'm sure you
enjoy it I love that I watch sports I'm
not saying that you shouldn't it's just
not my process cuz it doesn't matter the
only thing I care about is the audience
the only thing I care about is the
audience and so that's why I read all my
comments that's why I have insights on
this is why I got into places like amped
to your judgment like once you
understand that somebody knows
everything that they should be doing you
have to ask why they're not doing it you
start getting into mommy and daddy
issues you start getting into
insecurities you start getting into a
lot of people here not building personal
brands because they have skeletons in
their closet and once they get public
they don't want to deal with the
ramifications there's real [ __ ] out here
I always enjoy the skeleton in his
closet people get really weird of the
[ __ ] out like people's faces get funny
next question comes from Veronica how do
you get in with the right people for
example if you want to get in with the
people who choose the light bulbs for
the next multi billion dollar hotel
Veronica you have to reverse engineer
people it's really easy you know who the
decision-makers are by title follow them
on LinkedIn Facebook Instagram Twitter
and see what they care about and if
they're into things that I've talked
about already footie or Margaret River
Cabernet that is your gateway there's a
reason people played golf or have steak
dinners they get to know people they get
to know their spouses they get to know
things that make them tick and then they
exploit them if you want to go cynical
with it or they just use them to do
business but Sarah who makes that
decision is the person that you need to
reverse engineer and so in what one of
my favorite things about social media
today in a b2b environment is following
the people that you want to do business
with and figuring out what they love and
then if to me I think manipulations
scary so for me I'll never when I know
something about somebody make pretend I
like it too I'll look for the things
that I have a common interest in and
I'll lean in there or of a teammate that
has a common interest or I'll just
reference that interest just showing
respect that I understand what's going
on I think too many people fake people
try to do that to me all the time that I
Gary vo the Jets right on big Jets fan
like name the offensive line they're
like oh [ __ ] you so I think I think you
have to be careful to fake it for the
sake of business which is why I always
bet on authenticity and so but you can
reverse engineer that person yeah very
good
next question comes from Charmaine
what's the best way to support teenage
kids who have an entrepreneurial mind
and limited
to assets well limited assets is the
best [ __ ] thing for any entrepreneur
I mean I don't know how people haven't
realized that here's the secret
adversity is the foundation of success I
mean like the you know the skip this
would scare me a lot more if they had an
entrepreneurial mind and had tons of
assets entitlement and too much
abundance creates zoo animals and so I
mean that one's like to me take more
away from them I mean it like and
definitely don't dwell on things like to
me I think the thing that my mom did
really well was she saw that I was
entrepreneurial and she doubled down on
it and she punished me for bad grades
but she didn't make me feel like that
was the most important thing in the
world and so I think finding a balance
of raising a child with entrepreneurial
you know aspirations finding a cadence
between them respecting things but also
leaning in on their strengths but it's
interesting that the person put limited
means it means that they're feeling some
insecurity that there can't give their
kid $10,000 boost that's the best thing
that happens like put a kid out there
that has to learn how to eat for
themselves the best thing that ever
happened to me was when I rolled up on
my mom in fifth grade I was like mom
everyone's getting Nintendo I want
Nintendo she looked me dead in the face
with her Russian accent she said go buy
it so then I [ __ ] shoveled snow and
[ __ ] raked leaves and washed cars and
sold lemonade and from a very young age
I learned how to make money for myself I
genuinely think entitlement is poison
abundance is poison for entrepreneurs I
genuinely think restrictions limits and
lack of resources are the foundation of
the best entrepreneurs very good next
question comes from Chris he says how
can I take my indie comic book from
being a small scale project into a large
brand that more readers will care about
and enjoy just as much as I enjoy
creating it Chris I think there's a
couple things one first of all you have
to understand the market is the market
and so for me two things that I would do
one if it's good I'm blown away by how
many people get mad at doing three
work all these creators get mad at free
it's so laughable I always do [ __ ] for
free and we'll continue to do things for
free because it creates leverage and
context so what I would do Chris if you
can afford it and if you couldn't afford
it have a side hustle that lets you
afford giving away three thousand a
thousand two thousand of the comics go
to a Comic Con go to use online hashtags
of people that are interest just give it
away the attentions worth more than
anything else it's and I always say
watch what I do not what I say there's a
reason I don't sell products there's a
reason I don't have masterminds or
ebooks or things of the nature I give
away all my content for free because
your attentions more valuable than
extracting money from you
so I would give away the comic book at
scale mmm very good next question last
question number six comes from Pam she
says what's the number one piece of crap
thinking or behavior that gets up your
nose she wants to know what this room
needs to hear to start doing better and
business and life man I like you pam pam
there's a lot i mean look there's
there's so much i mean look the thing
that really drives me crazy and I just
spoke to it is entitlement like anybody
here that thinks anybody owes them
anything is already in deep [ __ ] like
it's just like entitlements stunning
number two the thing lack of patience
that's why I push it so hard like you
want to make a million dollars a year
and you think that's supposed to happen
in the first 2 3 4 5 7 years of you
doing something it's laughable people
have gotten so crazy about the one or
two things like uber and Instagram
without realizing that that's point like
you're more likely to win the lotto then
start a company that looks like that
you're more likely to get struck by
lightning seven times
than starting anything that looks like
uber or Instagram so just people's
perspective is completely [ __ ] like I
I don't understand what people are doing
out here they I don't like go you know I
don't know what it is in Australia to
look this up but like the medium income
levels compared to what people are
aspiring to in America
if you make 440 thousand dollars a year
you're in the 1% earners in one of the
richest countries in the world if you
make 440 thousand dollars a year in
America you're in the 1% that's the
bottom of the 1% but you're in the 1%
yet everybody's walking around like if
they don't make a million bucks
they aren't they haven't even started
doing anything and so perspective
entitlement complete lack of patience
like it's this stuff is hard and takes a
lot of work and just kind of like the
route like clearly what gets in in my
nose which I like the way you put it is
the when we transition to this QA and I
had a rant for two more minutes I I
can't wrap my head around how many
people have consumed the same [ __ ] for
me 67 times in written form in audio
form in video form in an 88 page deck
form and LinkedIn for like I do like I
spend millions of dollars saying the
same [ __ ] [ __ ] in four hundred
thousand ways hoping today is gonna be
the [ __ ] day that [ __ ] pisses me
off BAM
now's the lat I was the last question so
any last words you flew 36 hours you're
here the last words you want a sign can
I ask you a question yes that's just I
have to reward that ridiculous sign good
I'll repeat it I'm here come up here
let's top it up from their hands yo I'm
Yours I'm Yours buddy hold up the sign
that you guys made that means stand up
and hold it up it's such a piece of [ __ ]
but it worked
this is come on come up here a
mirror-like bring your [ __ ] sign this
is perfect this is attention arbitrage I
mean how much does this piece of [ __ ]
cost like a dollar look at this but it
worked
jump what's your question you have a mic
for him or you could speak into my mic
argue mine currently 15 years old 15 yep
okay for this that's a great decision
yep my question is is there any chance
you could be elemental so Jesus
definitely not mainly on the back of
like I don't even know how people like I
don't even talk to d-roc I barely talked
to my mom and my brother I don't want to
stand up here in front of like I don't
care how much they owe and Hum I have no
interest in bullshitting you I think I
think mentorship is an interesting thing
here's what I would say for you one
especially with me nobody is spending
more time and energy and resources
trying to show people what to do
it's literally like I'm putting it out
every day so like mentorship super easy
number two what I will do is I'm more
than happy to give you a summer
internship on my team
[Applause]
so if you can figure out how to get to
America I'm sure you will you made a
[ __ ] sign and so wouldn't use that as
a boat you can just just get on them
happy to do that for you send me an
email
all right good job take care
fun take the [ __ ] d-roc eat still shots
these days I can sign it hold this up D
rocks been [ __ ] bugging me awesome
you got a pen there you go markers nice
now here's the most important part of
this you have to sell this on eBay
number I love you
[Applause]
something do something please thank you
[Applause]